annie and i are both doing stand-up on
the road and we're going to be so much
fun i want you to come see us i got a
lot of shows coming up and i cannot wait
to see you guys it is
amazing at estheronics.com for tickets
the people who come to our shows are
amazing traveling is such a nightmare
but seeing you guys is like i i like i
don't even know what to say like i will
cry thinking about it it's unbelievable
we love coming your city eating your
food that's what i like to do
[Music]
i guess not oh my god we filled in with
another filipino mm-hmm oh she's almost
racist that's a shame that uh she's not
here for this
are you half i am half yeah what if he
was full and it just changed
yeah one time i was like you look so
asian in this and you're like i'm asian
yeah that's why i go why do you look so
asian he's like i am that's the that's
the secret
literally known you for 27 years i mean
yeah it's um
don't plug bad for me i'm half but it's
like
i'm definitely more i feel like uh yeah
i'm like white passing i'm white i'm
white at the end of the day but i am i'm
happy you're a white man wait that's
like carlos carlos is white
but i identify as hispanics oh my god
it's like george
you're a white lover you're just
pointing out all white people but carlos
oh my god it's just like all our white
boys
i mean like the world the world
generally receives me as a as a white
man but excited but that
i've anime eyes i have beautiful disney
princess eyes we can maybe zoom in and
really do
but yeah i
am uh yeah i mean well maybe after after
the joe coy movie comes out where i'm
joking son people when you're joking
people will be like okay yeah this man's
this is a filipino boy you know
i feel limp i feel this now
filipino man i mean this is what i love
i love carlos handing me things
carlos it was four dollars and a block
away and i want to make sure george pays
for every pony i want george to fund
carlos to deliver yes that's that's the
key okay wait so brandon walked in and
literally the first thing you said was i
have to tell annie she can't bring up
the time that she saw me crying i said
i'm gonna bring up a time he cried and
he's gonna be mad because i brought it
up every time it's fine it's fine we can
talk about we can talk about it we can
talk about it in no cuts i want to how
about we're not going to talk about it
and you guys just have to deal with no
we didn't talk about the time that you
saw me cry as a high school senior
i've known you since such a
baby boy you were talking about getting
your dick sucked by yourself in the
shower wait how did you know when i was
in high school
new york well she was living in new york
at the time i was living in d.c
but i would come up for stuff sometimes
and he was like he was like the boy
wonder comic in dc and he would come up
and now look at me a former child
prodigy you kind of are yeah when did i
meet you being an ex-child i still look
young though i still look i still play
young i mean esther knows esther knows
oh my god it is weird that you guys are
like we have something you have you're
way more youthful you and andy are you
guys and andy melinakis
did when did i meet you
uh probably like 20
15. so you were you when
yes do either of you have chrome's
crohn's disease annie what that's
interesting
why yeah because crohn's disease people
look young usually when they have
chronic no they don't they're wrong
type in johnny pemberton
i'm right and johnny have that and yeah
johnny is i will call my friend right
now who has crohn's and and tell them
they look old and yeah
esther you're a [ __ ] i will yeah i mean
johnny johnny was playing high schoolers
deep into his 30s i think he would
could still do it and he's got longer
hair now it's working yeah how old are
you in joe's movie i play like a 17 year
old boy despite being 29 i'm a 29 year
old man wait a 29 year old man i play a
17 year old boy in this movie and i will
be uh
like i had this thought on set where
like first first day we're filming it's
like uh you know a character the the
dad is yelling at me you know like oh
you have a c plus in math and like my
internal monologue is just like i'm
gonna be 30 when this is on demand you
know um do you tell them about
do you remember the counter i made for
your birthday oh for
when i'm i turned 30. i what you were he
was doing like old people jokes or
making fun of people for being old i was
not i think i was maybe just being i
think like you were trolling you maybe
you started the troll the the troll yeah
you're kind of an og are you going to
troll us today no no no no no no
i'm i'm mind my own business
i'm not i feel like we do have hits our
stories are hits we got lost hiking
oh we did get last time i mean it was it
got too dangerous yeah what's going on
between you guys it felt like a teacher
maybe that was like
yeah
i know and now i'm into half asians
oh okay
okay
that's the twist we mommy son
you would be jealous so jealous i had
there was like one there's a somebody i
well i'm not gonna say
names but there's there's somebody in
comedy who
i was hooking up with that is i i think
seven seven years older uh and i found
out later that she used to be a
substitute teacher
at the high school that i went to at the
hospital
while i was there
i think it was like a secondary school
so i think i was in eighth grade when
she was a substitute teacher and then
years later we we both uh were just sort
of at the same shows and
you know and things happened things
happened you know but i don't you don't
you guys put the you do you have you
never had a rule against hooking up with
comedians
what kind of question is that what it's
not because some people do some people
do it
i know the fat pigs you've dated
monsters i know the pieces of fat
garbage you dated
um
no i it's not that i didn't have a rule
as i i just you know i they all try and
she can't [ __ ] them all no i know but
it's not it really is not try it's not
fair it's definitely not fair the
being you know dating
female comics versus dating male comics
is not
i feel like it's better it's easier to
be the boy to be the boy
when you get to write all the jokes and
we just sit there and go hi you guys are
so good hehe can we suck her dick
every time i suck a dick from now and be
like is it a funny dick or an unfunny
there's only two kinds of just like why
are you treating like a chuckle [ __ ]
my point is like don't why are you
treating there's chuckle [ __ ] out
there i'm not i'm the one that makes the
chuckles speaking of dating comedians
yes i never again have
something to share
whoa there's a comedian a male comic who
i think is like my perfect guy and i
don't know what to do
yeah oh i want to play a guessing game
then do it he's definitely hideous
he just had a unattractive there was a
uh there was just a there's a showtime
doc about him that just came out was
there
oh no bill cox
is older
he's he has a lazy i haven't picked him
up yet he's my dream guy and he's
currently up very popular become a dream
guy because he drugs you and you fall
asleep and dream
[Laughter]
are you are you newly single no no she's
fully engaged no fully engaged but on
this show we live in an alternate
reality oh okay i'll say this i have i
don't think i have a chance with him but
i
i love i is he a little person no okay
he's a he's like a very popular stand-up
comedian right now especially right now
okay it's a he
this is where i know it's not true
oh
he's gay no esther's guy tim dillon
we're saying he do you have a crush on
tim dylan i do
it's tim dillon i guess he's my perfect
man
what do i do
um
[Music]
hmm
i've got you've gotta work to each other
i'm stumped annie and he's and he can't
and he has to leave
just like the two of you together is
like my nightmare when i when i see you
guys it's like esther's like it's fan
girl it's like please stop that's what
it is i really i have a crush on him i'm
attracted to him she goes like
do you think he'll do our po i'm like
esther you're being low self-esteem it's
like crazy she's like he's here
see i'm like i'm star struck and like i
he's like my type yeah he's like but i'm
his i'm his type adam friedland is his
type yes i know that he's been on he's
been on record about this he's been on
you he's been on record
he's been on me yeah he's been on record
tim tim has been on record about wanting
to [ __ ] me and wanting to [ __ ] adam
friedland so you would be the if he
liked girls you would be the one
i can't believe i'm revealing this on
the day we have someone who
is in my spot
that i want to be in yeah
should we fight i was gonna say i can't
believe you wear those pants this is i
like them
oh yeah you did kind of come
jam jammied up
jamied up jammies pajamas pajamas this
is like pretty dressed up for her that's
not those are those aren't they're nice
i like it's a fun it's a fun fun pattern
they just look like pajamas because i
sit like weird it is i feel like it's a
very uh l.a i am not flawed i'm in love
with you being really romantic towards
you that is so weird no you're bothering
me
language get a body language expert
later you're being awfully flawed is it
because he's in the kalila chair
she's like she's going to sniff that
chair no matter who's sitting in it
esther by the way did you buy yourself a
neck diamond no this is from my stylist
and it's not real are you kidding me but
it is i'd realize that when you wear it
i thought like maybe you like like let
your
fiance throat [ __ ] you and he got you
like a ring for it
[Laughter]
that's a really good plan
put a ring put a
girls girls love tim dillon they do like
i well i mean like i don't know
he was on a
red scare and i feel like those girls
are great i love them yeah they're great
um but they
i feel like they've they've talked about
tim dillon being like a [ __ ] man
they like a man with authority
he's like he is he like is he like is
alpha and he does he is
he's like a confident i just like fat
guys i don't know is it yeah he's not
bad
[Laughter]
i mean
and whitney was like he's sensitive i go
i'm not worrying about what tim's
sensitive about he's gone
did i ever tell you i think i might have
told this on here before but i never
told you this i gained weight over the
pandemic but i was kind of like in
denial about it like i was like
no maybe it's not that noticeable this
is a beautiful this is a beautiful top
thank you so much
now he's flirting i mean this is well
listen i was his teacher
my eyelashes are just flinging off and
everybody knows it sends me into a rage
would you ever wear
a half
crop top shirt as a as a man
i don't i don't i i'm not into that kind
of thing would you ever do nail polish
what's that nail polish absolutely not i
have i'm on record about how i think
that straight guys
who get painted fingernails i i think
they're sexual predators yeah they're
problematic yeah they're because it's
like queerbaiting it's like am i queer
maybe you should please
[ __ ] you that's what we should read on
the show and it's like
yeah guys with
colorful fingernails i think are guilty
of gray area section okay we're reading
is the thing i felt but i never knew the
term i really have had guys where you're
like you get so comfy with them thinking
they're gay and then they lean in for a
kiss and you're like yeah you just
played you gay played there's guys that
are yeah they're gay for [ __ ] i'm like
this is the crazy like it's really like
no it's a real thing where they're like
they like act all girly and stuff and
then you're like it's predatory behavior
yeah wait that's crazy i like have a i
do have it's funny that you brought that
you brought that up i i do have a joke
on stage right now where i ask like oh
are there any straight guys here with
painted fingernails and if a guy raises
his hand
you know i'll be like oh what's your
name and he'll be like uh dave or
whatever and i'll be like dave's a
sexual predator david i'm glad you said
that can we clip just that out wait
that's so funny
thank you that's well it's i don't know
that he says that person is a sexual
predator
it's like that's why it is that's how i
um no i've never had a guy where i
thought he was gay and then hit on me
that's never happened to me maybe that's
happening
i've lost my gaydar completely or people
have just learned that it's a way to get
girls um annie how is florida did anyone
bring you any gifts i got great gifts i
wish i remember to bring them i got like
i'll bring it next time i got this
really cute hat
and i did want to shout the girls out
but i can't remember the name of their
thing but i will cute earrings did
anyone bring you lip scrub for me you
got lip scrub
and two cities ago yeah two cities ago
did you request her lips are so crusty
and disgusting that our fans are now
intervening
they're getting involved they're coming
to my show yes this is the danger of
like a video pod yeah i know you're like
you're hidden away well yeah now i'm
gonna now i'm are you getting a gun out
of your no i'm just gonna
the world's smallest gun so long she has
like a little pink girl gun
it just made me want to chat i'm glad
that you had that instinct because i was
worried as i started saying i was like
oh no crusty lipstick i would hate to
like
yeah do you only take baths
i'm not a bathroom that's her i take
only about every day only baths
you don't shower no i only if i'm in a
hotel room and there's no bath i will
shower if i have to like if i'm there
for four years you're kind of just
soaking in your own filth that's a
misconception
because don't you i i've
what my impression was you you go bath
followed by a quick shower
that's soak are you catholic
uh not i read why i was at one point
okay i think that's why i think catholic
people like have to shout out god boy
i'm not oh look at our god boy guys our
first god
we have a god bless i was raised
catholic church this is a this is a take
i have i think catholic people like need
to bathe more than regular people
is that offensive what's that what's
that about it's anti-anti-semitic
it's the opposite no like they like need
their showers like every time i'm with a
catholic person they're like
they like think i'm so dirty i just made
a correlation what with you and showers
and why you don't like showers oh annie
yeah we all know what it's gonna be i
what the holocaust and the guests
why would you say that
i moved to edit that out that was very
insensitive
she's sick and disgusting
she's sick what a sick [ __ ] wow esther
to be a chosen one and speak that way
she's
horrible i'm sorry between her and the
god boy over here what's going on i want
to formally apologize for the joke i
made it was not funny i made a statement
with the the adl
wait i was gonna say okay so the what
reminded me when i said god boy is i
think the greatest insult you can give a
girl is to tell her she looks like she
only uses pads
calling someone a pad girl is so why i
just want to know why is it so bad so
only oh my god she is a bad girl i just
want to know why
because it's staying on you remember
what they would say in in uh like
in middle school
girls would be like oh if you use a
tampon then you're not a virgin anymore
oh my god that's very good i mean i went
to catholic middle school
catholic middle school yeah girls would
say that girls would be like oh if you
use a tampon you're no longer a virgin i
can't believe i did to you people god is
so crazy i know if you can if you can
love me like this you can let me like
this you look beautiful there's a
flapping eyelashes
it's obstructing my view
our eyelash budget we need we have
issues
george what was the name of my e-show
with julian mccullough we have issues oh
really yeah he named it we went we
actually have issues with the name and
the budget and the budget
i had a show for four episodes i think i
was friends with you during this i had a
show a talk show on e for four episodes
and they didn't
give us like a time slot like if you
went on like your tv to try to dvr it
would say programming
and then on the imdb they had another
girl's face under my name it was so cool
it was good though it was like better
than that
that's like a flex there's something
that's a flex about you saying that it
said e-programming you're just flexing
like
i don't give a [ __ ] i love that yeah
that's good energy i mean that's like
you know everybody i feel like that's
kind of a rite of passage is to have a
failed yeah just being involved in
something i think so tell you basic
cable thing that like never really
worked out i had a friend i'm not gonna
say his name but he literally quit
comedy because he got edited out of um
a season of america's got talent and i
was like i didn't know how to explain to
him like every successful person has
this exact story yeah wait i think i
auditioned for america's got talent and
didn't even get past the producers they
like canceled the show
like we're done hyman does like i'm out
they're like they're like
[Laughter]
that he he got further than me and quit
no i it's very like uh it was just weird
because i'm like you think there's one
there's not one thing
he sounds weak of spirit
i know let's [ __ ] beat him up
is something preventing you from
achieving your perfect life my fupa okay
well you can check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday why because betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist you can connect in a safe and
private online environment is so
convenient i love better hub this is the
best part you can start communicating
within 48 hours like if you have
something happening you know i'm not
just not well within 48 hours you don't
have to make the doctor's appointment
find a way to get there see where
parking is all that stuff wait in the
waiting room you can just go to
betterhelp.com and have an appointment
within 48 hours yes it's betterhelp.com
trash tuesday and you can send a message
to your counselor at any time that's one
of my favorite things that they have
because sometimes i'll be feeling really
stressed or frustrated and i can just
know that i can send the message
whenever i need to my counselor will get
it
and they have licensed professional
counselors who are specialized in
depression stress anxiety relationships
sleeping trauma anger so many more and i
did not sleep last night i could have
used a better help honestly we want you
to start living a happier life today and
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com trash tuesday join over
one million people who have taken charge
of their mental health again that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
trash tuesday when it comes to looking
good stitch fix absolutely has you
covered you can say goodbye to endless
browsing and hello to fresh picks that
are actually curated for your taste and
your size i mean you use a stylist from
your shows and stuff sometimes we can't
get to stylists you can just go to
stitch fix freestyle and their stylus
picking things perfectly for you i use
stitch fix my mom uses it i know you and
kaleila use it ever since we started
using it i feel like we've all
discovered really cool pieces and
they're like now staples in our wardrobe
and honestly this is true style icons
don't do it alone and neither should you
and if you need a hand finding pieces
that make you look good stitch fix has
you covered yeah you're never gonna
someone else is never gonna pick for you
the exact thing you would pick and you
would never pick what they're gonna pick
for you so it's like this great
experience to see if someone else can
take a shot at what will look good on
you yeah and also you have a different
opinion now and you're not just doing
your same old boring choices you're
making new choices that's something that
has really changed my life recently open
your mind open your closet
they have date night dresses they have
cozy clothes
your legs
and you can schedule a fix and a stylist
will send you five pieces that fit your
style size and price range with no
subscription required keep what you like
return the rest and to get started you
take the style quiz so stitch fix can
learn your preferences from your
favorite colors preferred fits and your
price range
it's really easy and you guys can get
started today by filling out your
freestyle quiz at stitchfix.com
tuesday and take advantage of free
shipping and returns that's
stitchfix.com tuesday to try stitch fix
stitchfix.com
tuesday
do you do you primarily date women who
are older or younger than you
uh
i would say mostly
i would say i mostly
younger but not that much younger mm-hmm
and are you scared to say that because
we're like old dried up no no no
i don't care
no i think uh you're both you're both
beautiful
what if we just it turned into like a
hand job
it's weird why are we jerking him off
now
yeah i'm their uh step brother
um
brother i'm trapped
i'm like trapped in a trunk um
yeah but generally in the same in
in the same range
and
yeah you don't care you don't it's just
yeah it just happens yeah there's just
now
well i just asked that because you dated
a girl who was like
who was older than you and my school
teacher and i'm like oh is that
something that you got into i mean yeah
i don't it's not like i'm not you're
always angling for like i'm not in
english
so
it's gonna be revisited in your tub
that's not what i do
my spanx hairy legs are gonna be
straddling the [ __ ] you don't know
myself
it's not like that
you are misreading my spanking it's
usually feminine i know
it's actually insulting she's calling
you a girl
i do have i i mean i have the you know i
have some i've soft features i have soft
speeder features like like that of a
beautiful woman it's weird that you kind
of now i'm realizing you look a little
bit like my boyfriend i've never we've
never had a you've always been
projecting the whole time onto me that
i'm flirting and spanking but look he's
your boyfriend
he's literally
half asian
he's too old to be my boyfriend he's
younger oh yeah yeah yeah
because i never my boyfriend's 27 but
the thing is that i never robert is
younger than you i never we never were
flirting though no flirty with me
i don't think so no i was a virgin when
we met why and then when and then after
she took care of it yeah uh
no yeah i was like you were yeah because
i was sleeping and i was 17.
i was 17. you're 17. i was letting you
be 15 in my memory yeah i was like 17
when i started doing stand-up and i
uh lost my virginity at 21. who did it
uh
oh it's like i
fully something i wanted i would tell
you off air
wow fully something i would tell you off
air
that is mildly embarrassing was it an
escort
no no no it's like but it's actually
where it's being
it being an escort would be better less
embarrassing yeah wow yeah
juicy
but the way you are looking and acting
is like you're going to masturbate to it
that is your no no no i refuse i don't
masturbate
wait i feel like that could be real
though do you not
sometimes i do yeah
i can go i could go nut without it
though i go in phases like i i have a
theory i think everyone is like this
where like you go through phases where
you really are like
hyped up and you need to do all you need
to get off all the time and then other
times where i'm just like gates are
closed like i don't need it
are you like that or a guy's not like
that uh yeah no i i think
reason recently i've kind of
uh carlos is taking notes by the way
he literally took it from the show not
for personal use while brandon wow
didn't say that and you got really
defensive for no reason okay you're all
into projecting now i'm like trying to
see where other people are projecting
as
yeah i'm doing the esther
esther's always got like her heel and
her vagina
she's like
she's always banging her [ __ ] yeezys
she's like yeah
it's just crazy how what a hoe you are
even when kalila's not here you're mused
that is your
no i feel like kalila can make you
squirt why would you say that because
it's true why even go there go there
i call come go go it's just a thing oh
sure yeah sure
welcome to the show do we have those
questions
let's oh man i the squirt is squirt piss
i think so yes
right
are you at the end of the day squirrels
i've only ever peed on guys so
yeah
here's one we could all answer what
makes you look at a woman as they walk
by is that a bad question what are we
doing to this man
why are we making him that was actually
more for you
to look at a woman or yeah no a woman
it's like because it is actually a
question for women it's like what makes
women look at other women i saw a thigh
gap that i almost went up to the girl
the other day at the airport and was
like your thigh gap is like
like a gift if we were together if you
had we would have talked we would have
she'd be here she'd be sitting
sitting
she'd be
gapping out in here it was insane i was
like oh my god your jeans never like rub
in the middle
what's the most intimate non-sex thing
that you do with a partner i know mine
it's holding hands
holding hands to me is so [ __ ] sexual
and intimate is it because of how wet
your hand gets and clammy
how [ __ ] like your tiny tiny hand is
answer the question [ __ ]
that's the most intimate thing
that's not sexual that you would do with
like a lover
i like to shower really shower with yeah
that's pretty that's pretty intimate i
enjoy i like to i like to
i have an open door bathroom policy i
like direct eye contact while either of
us were taking shits i i like well i
need to get a
one one flaw of my current living living
situations i feel like i don't really
have like i've had sex in my shower but
i feel like i don't have a sex shower i
have a sexuality yeah sometimes when i'm
like in a hotel like a nice hotel well
they're asking for it it's like what are
you not gonna it's literally like can
you guys sell me
on a sex and sucks in the shower because
it sounds horrible to me why do you why
are we already waiting
you're already wet you can wash it off
immediately you she likes to keep
becoming yourself
it is don't act like that's not a thing
you've actually i didn't respond did i
i had no response i think like yeah i
mean head head in either
on either end
yeah cause i got one of those seats so
it's like oh yeah you can go up
but my favorite move is because i have
one of those hospital beds my favorite
moves i scooch to the end of the bed and
then we present my vagina to my
boyfriend we just pull we bring me up
i would like to do a real slow one where
it's
there's no that's how you meant
it's just the thought would you
literally have a hospital yeah
i mean they're not they're like sleep
number one that would be a good way to
tease like to tease todd and be like i'm
coming up nope now i'm going down
you have to stay still he's like duct
taped to the floor
no
even not even just sex in the shower but
showering together with another person
is so uncomfortable to me it's like
who's under the water it's like fighting
for the warm water i don't yeah
oh i'm my i get the one it's todd yeah
my
you and tim dillon oh yeah i think we
know who's getting the water you know
you could probably be under a lot of
runoff
he's like a [ __ ] slip and slide for
you
you really could ride him you'd have to
climb on up
oh my god how have you met have you like
met have you tim met there's a picture
of the three of us where it like
literally looks like a reenactment of my
vagina there's like one giant they're
wearing the same color
has he been on has he been on the
opposite no not yet
oh wow do you know him have you been
yeah yeah he's been on the you're like
sit on the podium
you gotta have you should have him on
oh what's all this
this is actually think about not knowing
what's happening how scary that is
you're with two girls that are
interrogating you sexually
i know i'm sorry yeah what's going on
every episode we take a banana break if
like we just do it you know carlos is
calling them these days it's like
because sometimes tensions are high you
know it's a show for women and we're
like okay we need our potassium to calm
us down yeah i already i wake up i wake
up to one banana
every day you do
i eat one banana in the morning what if
that was you coming out
um
yeah
so you know i start i start my day off a
little banana i like that that's okay
it's a good snack good afternoon uh
honey christmas comes with his own bag
that's the greatest part
and you're never gonna refer to it is
that yeah it's like it's bad it's like
it's snack bag it's like it's like annie
that's not don't put your makeup in that
next time i see you this is the reverse
you're doing this
that's the beginning of a very bad
story
annie used to use a grocery bag to hold
her makeup last time she said this was
two weeks ago and then i pulled my bag
up and it was still a plastic yeah
something's never changed the sunglasses
have gotten more expensive no purses
do you know what's so like i don't know
what level of wealth you grew up with
but i grew up like
cheap middle class yeah so
in junior high i really wanted a coach
purse
and my dad found out and he said that i
should just use a grocery bag from jewel
oscar which was our grocery chain and
just write coach on it
and i'm like still feeling traumatized
so weird that i am your dad yeah you're
his no you're his dream daughter no but
your dad like even like
his he has worries about spending but he
has spent and the way he spent is how i
spent you were like you're chicago yeah
and you're philly yeah yeah okay cool
where are you from dc dc virginia
like military dads oh really air force
air force dad to moved around a bunch
and then i just say dc because that's
where i started white man or filipino uh
white man
white man filipino mom oh yeah that's
good why classic my todd i'm just
looking at baby todd here or he's older
than him oh my god that's so weird
that's actually so weird annie is very
confused sexually well yeah you met you
met me as a child as a sexless child
yeah but here's the thing so you are
still sexless to me and i don't mean
that to be like no because you because
of when you met me i think that i'm
happy but you you can acknowledge
success with the pus you've had you've
you
and i am
thank you i am proud and you could
acknowledge that i can i mean at the
time i was like you know i was like you
look exactly the same
yeah but i knew i know how to present
better this you have like a little bit
of like stubble
differences
yeah you're you're eight you're filipino
you're gonna be like boy for a long time
until you're just fully did you say for
a long time
wrong wrong asian
[Laughter]
why did you say long asian
um
esther i love that he called you out on
pajama wear and i know this is one of
your most expensive and amazing outfits
thank you well it's very you thought
about it for like a little this is a
very
this is where these cool pants let me
see the
oh my gosh wow yeah i mean we're someone
that's a very different size than you it
is sort of a
i mean it is it is an l.a look what it's
an la outfit this is a very la outfit
but it's not pajamas right it's not
pajamas but it is an la outfit in that
it is sort of i do think that there is
kind of an la sartorial
what's that word trend like clothes why
does everyone that sit here [ __ ] use
big words it's
i do think that you have the kalila
curse
folks do and this is something that i
have
been guilty of in my
i think or you know early 20s but
a lot of people in la do dress like
teenagers yeah comfortable for forever
yeah which i've i've tried to like
not do as i approach 30. i've never
placed that but that is exactly you're
no you're doing this this is kind of a
dress exactly like a friend wait carlos
thank you full dad right that's the
that's
what i'm going to shirts mom like art
teacher mom but the rest is dad carlos
what do you think because i feel like
you're like a men's fashion
activist i mean i kind of by the way
everyone's freaking out right now
they're like oh my god everyone in the
comments is watching this and they're
going in real time and they're going oh
my god esther's body is so hot i didn't
know she was covers and up
not that i read the comments portia
tells me
oh my god wait i didn't tell you guys
this i'm locked out of twitter someone
has stolen my twitter they're selling
nfts it's so embarrassing they're
crushing can i see do you have i can't
go i can't can i see you
can can somebody this is the first time
and i'm going humiliated i've not seen
it yet and i've been like trying to
avoid you haven't seen it
it's not that bad
everyone else seems to think it's bad
everyone's like oh my god this [ __ ] is
selling us and if somebody is falling oh
annie nft when i saw it oh my god you
know it looks like why should i like
that can we
blow this up i want to see this okay
insane and then x out of that change the
picture a couple of things i just said
yes the tweets crypto investor just
going into the hashtag nft by the way i
gained so many followers oh wow
the thing is i want to hire them they're
getting better luck on mine
no i literally first saw it before i
talked to you and was like oh andy's
having a really productive weekend
oh go down go down this is
a wild
did they delete your tweets prior maybe
i don't must have notifications
i'm gonna blame my other ones
so it's like my last one was retweeting
the comedy store and please go down what
else i retweeted
randy glades christmas hell yeah hell
yeah i named my dog after my lover
i stand him
oh wow and so then all of a sudden
somebody's posting about nft discord
it's like i would do like and i would do
like an nft that's not my own drawings
like i just do someone else's right i
say lean in i would say this is the new
you
oh it's so it's working you guys it's so
embarrassing no it's ripping off my
people i don't even want to like ever
but you were never really like
like twitter was never your thing i hate
twitter it was back in the day and then
once they started canceling people i was
like i'm out i was like oh god i really
came on here to do my worst jokes
i was like twitter is where you do your
jokes that like are kind of mean right
that's her you're like this is this is
my uh this is the website where i use
slurs yeah this is yeah
this is the slur website this is the one
brandon i feel like you are so i don't
call it twitter
i feel like you're so big on twitter but
it's like
i don't i i don't touch it that much you
don't i don't i leave it alone for the
most part where is your i'll pop in
every once in a while
remind them i still got it
no because you are super funny on
twitter thank you but like
where is because i feel like that's how
i got to know you like what's your where
are you expressing yourself creatively
then if you're not using i kind of
reserve
i kind of save save it for stand up and
yeah podcast that's cool or hacking
annie letterman i think yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it says brennan
yeah wait i said sorry brandon but the
um the it's like offensive that they
people think that's my back like why
would i put like that backwards you're a
trippy trippy visual i'm like so crazy i
think it's really not as bad as you
think
yeah now that i'm singing
you kind of like you know what's
annoying about it is that you like that
kind of [ __ ]
that's like the [ __ ] you like that [ __ ]
yeah the that
there's like animal ears
the the background the background
is like that's your love for your career
like i'm i'm gonna buy one i feel like
that's like a pattern that's like you
you make sweatpants with that yes it's
tie-dye thank you
so cute so well constructed people are
saying they really like it you keep it
no i do think my twitter account my my
like follows like they're doing great
they're doing better than me
listen once i realized i can't put any
edge on twitter my tweets turned into
retweets
i'm just like i'm on a show see ya
yeah yeah i try to yeah i don't like to
spend too much it's it's also like
really
it's it's different than it was yeah
when i was super active on there and i'd
regret there was like
i don't know i went back i i deleted a
lot of [ __ ] on there
really yeah i it's like there's like 800
something tweets on my account now
because i just sort of i was like ah
just nothing but the hits like anything
else like this doesn't need to exist
forever i used to use it i don't know if
you used it like this but i would like
do it as like a um
like an open mic kind of like before i
would go to open mics i would like throw
out my jokes but they're like horrific
it jokes about like
bad jokes i was gonna say something
that's like a theme of a joke i have now
so
i was like you have these horrible jokes
about oh wait i haven't seen i'm still
doing that
it's not the specific joke what is the
same genre
that's why i delete my tweets because i
don't want people to know i'm still
doing them
okay
for real how many free trial
subscriptions end up costing you
hundreds if not thousands this this is
like a sore subject it hurts it hurts
but it's important
we need to fight back against scammy
subscriptions with truville
truebill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need want
or just simply forgot about as a
currently hacked person online this
really touches close to home it's
you need control of what's going on
online you don't even know what you
signed up for you click a thing you
think it's 299. it's four leads years
later you've been spending 75 dollars a
month it's four years later you're
living in your car now you're live
you're back in your car it's a tesla now
it's a little warmer but it's still not
nice it's still a car
and true bill
on average helped people save
720 a year and because companies make
subscriptions hard to cancel like
literally they do that on purpose
trouble makes it so incredibly simple
you just link your accounts and shruba
will cancel your unwanted subscriptions
in one tap
and your true bill concierge is there
when you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to
truebill has over 2 million users and
helped save them over 100 million
dollars you've saved a lot of money with
true bill i have i've saved uh joe
rogan's spotify amount of money
you guys don't fall for subscription
scams start canceling today at
truebill.com trash tuesday go right now
truebill.com
trash tuesday it could save you
thousands a year
truebill.com
trash tuesday okay i'm really excited
about this sponsor because
i sleep with them every night ah is it
feminine it's
attitude no but honestly you're so good
are you still sleeping on cotton because
then your sheets are dirty cotton is an
incredibly wasteful thirsty and damaging
crop that uses dangerous pesticides and
drains the earth's water supply save the
thirst for instagram it's time to move
on to something cleaner softer and
better for the environment and it
doesn't have to cost a fortune
introducing attitude bamboo sheets
because bamboo is better in bed
bam
it's made from the world's first clean
bamboo fabric attitude sheets are softer
than silk sustainable as hemp and use
500 times less water than cotton sheets
they're so silky so they are really soft
i got them from my parents my parents
love them they're a cooler way to sleep
they're breathable moisture wicking so
dave likes them too they're better for
the plants why because your sweat's
wicked up because he gets hot
i'm a hot sleeper you're a hottie oh my
god it helps me so much i'm a coldie as
well i will wake up with just
who cares
no clue he does 90. i do 10. this is
what is happening we you guys
this bedding is so soft and comfortable
like whenever my attitude sheets are
dirty i'm in a bad mood like i need to
buy more because i need them all the
time they're dirty a lot as you can tell
and you can try any attitude betting
with their 30 night sleep trial if
you're not completely satisfied return
it for a full refund and right now you
can get 20 off your order plus free
shipping when you visit etitude.com
tuesday annie spell it
all right i gotta look at it hold on all
right guys is that drum roll please e t
t i t u d e dot com whoa slash
slash tuesday
baby this is attitude's best offer but
don't wait it's for a little only a
limited time i won't wait i'm doing it
today order today for free shipping and
20 off your order at etitude.com
tuesday you're gonna like them i have
the dark blue there's i feel like i'm in
the ocean
i will say like i've looked whenever i'm
like trying to write stand up i'll like
have a and i'm at like my last leg of
effort i'll be like let me see my tweets
if there's anything is that like one
minute yeah
and then there's nothing good on my
twitter your twitter's like cute you say
cute things oh you think i'm cute
they're like funny and cute no you're
credited what do you say what do you say
she'll be like no
eating a scone
oh
yeah just finished a scone off to piano
lessons
i mean i feel like father is letting me
out tonight this is a genre of twitter's
just girls being like
famously i love to eat a tiny little
cookie
that's like a genre of twitter there's
like girls there's like a kind of like
cutesy little like oh having a cute
little day you know what the genre i
hate is where it's like girls that are
like [ __ ] boys be like and i'm like come
on oh sure like i never want to see a
tweet that other people can tweet i
don't like that yeah like originality
like but you always singular voices
you'll have to check like i remember
when i would do twitter it'd be like
you're like in a race for these jokes
that other people could do
if you're trying to stay topical well
that's like that's something that i hate
is it is it's yeah i don't want to um
it just feels like um
yeah a lot of times on twitter
it i mean well
most people just aren't on it
yeah and so it's like it does feel like
kind of a waste of time to
just be like jumping on like oh i gotta
be the first person to make a joke about
this thing in the zeitgeist or whatever
like i don't wanna
i don't wanna be on there like oh i
gotta i gotta do my joke about
jordan peterson being on joe rogan or
like
oh p davidson's dating a famous lady oh
i know everyone making p dudes like i
don't want to
i i i want to stay out of it do you it
feels undignified
well it's just sort of like you're ever
just going after that it's like boring
and your account just retweeted a theo
nft
oh boy is it deal
no i checked
it's actually just some guy named theo
he seems ambitious
like you on twitter
this is
this theo guy and now he's just assuming
you're on his team right because you
didn't do anything can you watch my
instagram story how mad i was so
actually theo just called and he needs
you to meet him outside
locked out you take my car keys i'm just
trapped standing there wait can we watch
the video that annie puts on instagram
because it's so i was
so mad you're this is true you look like
you took a potion did this just happen
yeah within the last 24 hours yeah
happening it's been 48 hours no she just
posted this too i like in the middle of
the night was just like tossing and
turning like writing my age and like we
gotta get this down but i couldn't see
it so i didn't know what it looked like
why did you make your eyes because i
didn't want to do my makeup but it makes
it so much more confusing no but it is
like it's funny to hypnotize people
saying that i'm not the audience sees
sees this yeah
eyes are so what a setup guys why would
we be in this situation because you're
believing that i'm selling you crypto
a lot of i mean a lot of celebs are
i know but i'm like i'm not a regular
i'm a [ __ ] community which is it does
feel like truth but you are an artist
it's like i was like oh annie's like
it does it's like did you see the jimmy
fallon paris hilton nf2 thing no no
it's [ __ ] it it's really depressing
what is that it it feel it also feels
like they're both doing it against their
will
there's a video of like paris hilton
on the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon
and they're both presenting their nft
yes they are doing it against their will
and it feels like it feels like somebody
has like a [ __ ] gun to the back of
their head everyone everyone that's
talking about nfts is has a gun to their
head my business manager my first
meeting with him was like was like um oh
my god george of course is into
of nfts he's making a [ __ ] face oh
really are you making tiger belly out of
t
where's our where is our billboard
[ __ ] monster it's it feels
video
reese witherspoon is tweeting about nfts
i just feel very something weird is
going on
listen here's the thing i draw so i
understand why my business manager's
like let's do nfts i still don't
understand what they are i'm busy
performing in front of people you you're
like show kanye yeah i like that kanye
said that me too i liked that kanye did
that okay well let's watch it wait watch
this first watch the anger first because
this is real all right play from the
beginning so annoyed i have to post
about this my twitter is very obviously
hacked but for some reason people are
believing that i all of a sudden i'm
into cryptocurrency
you guys i've never talked to i'm so
really selling you cryptocurrencies
please forgot
a cartoon with a skateboard on the eyes
are you guys kidding me
annie the eyes
on my instagram or my twitter
it's hacked it's hacked i hate to get
back into it it's hacked do not be
stupid all right
i'm so annoyed that this is happening
but i'm more annoyed that you guys
out of nowhere i would just start
okay also if you haven't spent all your
money on the obvious scan on my eyes
there it is that's how it's done y'all
i like the best thing you've ever done
in my life like it is the eyes one part
before it cuts off
where it's like please don't follow
comedians
i was like yeah just stop there great
that's
like what yeah that's fun but i guess
that makes sense
just like you don't think it would be
the danny the video drawing i've been
squeezing as much as i can get out of
you don't think that would be the nft
the thing i've been doing the most i can
get uh
god damn what do you think of kanye
right now like what's your yay
positive i mean i was at the uh i was at
that la memorial coliseum oh you went to
that
[Music]
too because yeezy but it is yay
i thought the same thing
i was once like you uh
it was great i mean he did like
basically all of his hits in
chronological order he did yeah like
starting like through the wire
like he did everything so you're a kanye
fan yeah i've always been a kanye fan i
mean i i didn't love the like christian
era oh okay
i didn't love that one album that's like
mostly
wyoming but i like that he is i think
it's weird is it post-divorce he's god
boy you know he's being horny again and
wait a second but
him saying that pete has aids is so
funny it is very funny that's there it
is very funny even though he did it one
of the funnier things that i've ever
heard in my life it's very funny whether
he did it or not it's also funny if
people made it up it's also funny the
whole thing is it is really it is very
funny to say that your ex-wife's
boyfriend has a it's just like this
famous guy
i don't care who it is
it's yeah
did you have like a rivalry with pete
because you were like the young boys no
i don't think we never crossed paths you
were like east side and he was he's new
york we've never we've just never i mean
like i think it was new york
no i was never but i had never lived in
new york
but you were with us we never yeah we
don't know we don't know each other
yeah
so kanye well kanye
posted
my focus is on building real
i can't read this by the way i literally
i'm like this isn't i feel like yeah
every time i do the ads i'm like oh no
my focus is on building real products in
the real world real food real clothes
real shelter do not ask me to do a
[ __ ] nft yay
and then he says
ask me later which i think is so funny
that's a very funny postscript exactly
how i talk to my parents i'm like do not
[ __ ] ask me that right now
ask me later talks to their parents like
that me it's really bad
yeah i i've recently become really a big
kanye fan
recently yeah i'll tell you why like
where you she copies carlos cause carlos
got me into yeezys and now
but you weren't a fan of his music no
because i
literally i didn't know any of his music
that's why i'm having i'm such a fan now
because i'm rediscovering all the music
and i've been asking have you guys heard
jesus walks
have you heard the song jesus walks yeah
also didn't you just like get into weed
yeah i just started hilarious you're 33
years old and you're just like man
there's
you guys have you guys heard kanye west
or smoked marijuana
it's working out so well though we're
all so happy about it it's so that's so
funny i'm partying man i'm so
i'm like i'm like post i'm post weed you
are what do you mean i was like i was
super into weed like uh when i was
10 years younger than you
but now i don't know it's i don't know
it doesn't
both i mean i kind of i will like i like
those five milligram camino gummies now
yeah those are nice it's like a nice
five millimeter but
the but like i don't like smoking weed
esther's like asleep in museum well she
would be asleep in a museum if she was
high or not but
esther like will be like walking
sleeping
she takes so much weight she'll be like
that is a little bit of an exaggeration
not really george and carlos were there
is that how you would describe this you
got to try uh esther you got to try
ketamine why oh it's great
it's awesome
yeah
why what does it do
it's like a really pleasant dissociative
experience like you dissociate just
enough it's relaxing she's been judging
me because i got an ulcer from doing too
much i was never judging you because i
was in love with it i thought it was so
much fun you know you know about you
know about cocaine and what people call
doing cocaine and ketamine what is it uh
like the party gay community they call
it calvin klein why
i don't know because ck
calvin klein i'd call it pull that dick
out
yeah yeah yeah that's so funny and we
all got to yeah we all got i have been
saying i was setting myself up to do
that but he didn't fast enough everybody
else i didn't say
you guys saying this you got i've been
saying this for months
that happened with my friend that
happened my friend the other day where i
like said something to her
and then um and then later i was like i
said it again
and she was like i love that and i was
like you should use it and she's like
i made it up and i was like oh no do you
ever have those with your friends we're
like i don't care you made anything up i
don't care yeah please lord take it lord
take it
yeah it's just weird in comedy because
we're all a little bit of hacks and then
everyone if you if you accuse me of
stealing your joke you gotta really know
they stole it
because that could be really
embarrassing one time i was able to
google image a
a joke of my own like there was like a
meme i was like oh she's so embarrassing
you know what
happened one time uh recently was i
i told i told the joke i told it twice
and the first time i told it it was
another comic was like oh i actually
just wrote it i wrote a joke just like
that and i always have just written it
you're like oh that's weird and just
right while i was on stage
it was like no it was like not i don't
know if if i have a joke that's similar
to somebody else's i would mention it i
just do it faster you would television i
just get it yes if i have like the same
joke as somebody else like i would say
something wow
like that but
that does not happen oh yeah but have
you ever had that happen of you
oh no i had this is where annie tells me
i stole her whole ass
yeah i would that's not my actual
i've tried to get her to steal my act
i've begged you to take jokes um
oh i was i was gonna say i i did a joke
at a at a show
where i mean this is it was honestly
like kind of a hack joke i think because
it was right after
the it was right after brittany was free
and i was like oh how it would be really
funny if she just immediately shot a guy
you know
and
like
a great joke um but i did that at some
jo some show at like union hall
and uh there was like a couple in the
front
that
like the the joke got a laugh from the
crowd but there was a couple in the
front and one of them was like oh my god
we were just talking about that and i
was like like like the couple was saying
that they were just making that joke to
each other
that day and then i was like i was like
i'm not doing that again you know what
that's a topical joke and i feel like
that happens like that's not that big
and that's like i think that that's why
it's like best to like stay
away from topical stuff because it's too
easy to run into this it's also like
there's no longevity in it it's fun
this is my one strength as a comic i'm
gonna flex it i'm so obsessed with
myself that i would never consider
topical jokes like i'm it's all about me
oh i thought you're gonna say jokes
i would never consume
wait do you guys watch euphoria yeah i
do it's a lot of stuff happening this
season oh this last episode was good i
didn't see the recent one oh you're
gonna like it but yeah i mean first
first episode out the gate when feza
fez beats up uh
he's the best character freaking uh nate
jacobs so oh yeah oh that's something i
tweeted in 2019 it's from know your
meme.com well yeah now euphoria high
school has become a meme but i tweeted i
was i made the joke about euphoria high
school years ago yeah
but this happens this has happened a few
times it says hey what's up guys i'm the
new kid here at euphoria high school why
are all the lights purple why don't any
of the kids hear two homework you know
this is this is a 2019 joke this was
first season why is everyone dressed
like esther pavitzka and now everybody's
making you for your high school jokes on
there yeah
i just got scared that i said it like
christina's last name no but those are
because they're similar is her i justin
martindale brought me up on stage the
other night and he said that i was the
lunch lady on euphoria and i was like he
nailed it he cast me so well
oh my god
so welcome i was did oh i did i did
audition like several times for the new
season you did obviously i did not get
it i was your agent no if i was your
agent i would be doing the exact same i
was like gotta get about the show like i
was i was really
i want i thought i i was like maybe
you'd be like let's just say you'd be a
nail polish
but
i i will say there was like that one the
first episode the first episode of the
new season
it's uh
it's that scene where like maddie's
banging on the bathroom door right yeah
and she meets that guy
right
a guy she meets a guy who's like
uh
he's like a big black guy on the show
and he's played by uh young meech i
believe but i auditioned for that and i
remember once i once i actually watched
the show and saw
like i thought that i really nailed the
audition and then i watched the show
and it's like a big black guy the
greatest and i was like why would you
it was mean for you to make me audition
no but here's the thing when you when i
was listening to someone that was always
going to be that guy yeah then you don't
you can the blames off you they just
wanted a different type they weren't
sure yeah but yeah i've had that too
where it's like
like why'd you
even i can't there's certain shows i
like i have to wait a full season before
i can watch them because i'm like i'm
still salty i didn't get the part
i know that feeling like
yeah how's doll face doll face is coming
out or it's out right now i'm so i'm
really excited yeah you look cute and
all the things they make they
they kind of like upped your regular
game i feel like do you feel that way
too
i'm struggling right now with
i was i
to be completely honest i was heavier
when we filmed for
health reasons
and i'm now less heavy and so it's real
every time i see the promo all i think
about is like that i look should you
just like ask for them to do reshoots
right now yeah we only just reshoot my
part
you'll have power in hollywood when you
can do that when you're like listen blur
the background we'll cgi me back in
we'll green screen it i just feel like
now i've i've done my worst fear i've
manifested my worst fear which is
drawing attention to my weight
fluctuations on camera like this is my
gift to the world if you guys want to
have fun with all the ups and downs of
my way well that's like the problem with
if you're like podcasting you can't be
you're putting it all out there all the
time yeah it can't be like an elusive
interesting time for you to spread your
legs like oh yeah you're kind of just
kind of just putting it all out there
you know well have you have you ever
watched schultz's andrew schultz's
podcast it's at crowd oh no
like this it's so crazy i'm like oh my
god like you have to really squish it
down
it's always like his penis is like
touching the
camera no yeah
i'm like i guess i like it down here
i do feel powerful does he have two
podcasts he has flagrant too which i
don't know why it's called two yes or
two because
uh the other guy
with the kash yes
i think i met him at montreal like years
ago it's funny because he i feel like
his online thing now is he's like tough
guy
right like
he's like he's like
controversial yeah but i just think of
him as like such a sweet guy yeah he is
really nice he's oh charlemagne the guy
did you uh
you were working with that i did yeah i
did i did
oh you did yeah i watched that it was
really good oh you wait you you were on
the breakfast club like recently yeah
i gotta watch i want to go again i want
to go again
that was so cool because i i recently
discovered kanye west this new artist
and some of his greatest interviews were
on breakfast club as i am now teaching
you about and soulja boy has the best
ones oh it's the number one soulja boy
has the best breakfast club videos yeah
and takashi six nine okay yeah oh yeah
mine was like controversial or anything
i i i hope to go on and and up my
no i watched yours i was like i can't i
was like watching kanye over and over
and then i saw you cowboy hat and it was
the day the day i came up with a cowboy
hat i had a black cowboy hat and
sunglasses
the vogue cover came out with um beyonce
and a black cowboy hat and i was like hi
man
am i not a trendsetter
but it was someone said i looked like um
i was on a rock of love or not rock of
love what was the one that's their walk
of love as the male lead
that's what i saw
on my screen
how's the slash just making it i think
my my favorite breakfast club moment is
when um hillary clinton said she has a
hot sauce in her bag wait what
that was awesome everyone embarrassed i
was like i was happy to be like a white
person that didn't that was an awesome
moment when she said
oh yeah i keep hot sauce in my bag
in my bag
i you know did you see the ad for a
there's a master class it's like hillary
clinton's like
it's a it's like all black and white and
it's hillary clinton or maybe it's like
just dark tones and she's like
she's like here's the speech i was gonna
read and she's like about to cry
and then um and then she goes i'll read
the full speech on masterclass.com oh
yeah i'm like this is like you got
hacked mitch did you just get hacked
because i'm signing up for that is
what's what's the class how to be a
[ __ ] loser it's so embarrassing to
still be crying about it
she's still crying it's crazy
the most embarrassing thing was the
glass ceiling that they had a glass
ceiling and this thing that was dark
brutal when they were like they were
ready
i just want to say that i really want a
female president well who is it going to
be it shouldn't be her
it shouldn't be her i'm going to go out
and let me say this i do not pay
attention to politics at all i don't i
just will not i'm done i was a big big
bernie guy
yeah that's right um i have a beautiful
bernie poster in my office love him your
office
are you a [ __ ] idiot for saying that
in front of me you're awful you [ __ ]
stupid idiot you know the room i'm
talking your office your trash where you
slip on the
couch
her office is a garbage den
the [ __ ] are you talking about you
stupid it is true that when i first got
my new couch in my office that i was so
excited about it i slept on it for like
three months
dave was like what's going on
i
yeah i mean there's something about
sleeping on your own couch falling
asleep on your own couch i love a couch
there's i i have like a mythical
feeling around that like i just think
that's the coolest thing is someone who
falls asleep on their couch i have like
a romantic view up here really i've
deserved no i will beg dave i'll be like
dave let's do sleepover in the living
room tonight and he's like no i can't
move my mask
oh it's so sad we gotta get him a rolly
one
what's your deal what's like the whole
thing with you in sleepovers i i i've
only seen snippets of this but i i saw
like one clip where you're like guys i
keep saying we need to do a sleepover
episode i grew up like having sleepovers
all the time and i just love them so
that's what she called sleeping on her
parents floor
i also had it like
well there's i feel like a lot of
whatever just i love sleepovers yeah
yeah there's nice
well rick glassman thinks you stole it
from him i i know oh what's what does
rick glassman's do with sleepovers he
did i can't remember what it was he did
like a sleepover episode of his podcast
and then i was like
oh we were gonna do that too he accused
you of stealing it when you named your
no if he did that that's mentally ill i
think he did it
but we'll have to have him on to find
out
controversy hey wrecked glass when
you're going down brandon how are you
feeling right now do you feel like
you've been molested violated attacked
i love it this was fun i love it do you
feel safe and comfortable or do you feel
like the two women
oh i
yeah
i feel very at i would i you know i'll
do i'll do rogan hours
oh my god
i've not received the rogan bump yet it
is uh what if it was a bump what if
every time he went he gave you a bump of
something
people who are angry online
they're just like showing off how [ __ ]
up their own life is yeah it's like not
about online are you talking about my
angry rant
i it is embarrassing to post true anger
but i did think it came out funny so i
did post it anyway well like yesterday i
went through something that really
rocked my world oh please do tell no no
i'll obviously i'll we'll talk about it
another time but like i really wanted to
like
get angry online can i ask a question
directed at you
something that happened to me uh in my
in
like a business thing that someone said
to me and i was like i this is it this
is i've never done this but i'm and i'm
gonna i'm gonna
tell the world and i just was like you
know what
i actually was texting with carlos about
it he was like don't use like an app
that's past its prime twitter to like
also don't listen to carlos
that's not bad advice don't go crazy on
twitter
what is it
they're trying to get a hit here all
right
do you want us to have a good show or
not we need to do that
should we
did you have you shown feed on the
program
no
you're not going oh i forgot about our
um oh yeah what
we have heads we have heads hits
everything about us is what tell us we
okay so we got on the little rivalry
over the feet pixelation about where who
started it oh it wasn't really us which
now it's other people have run away
that it's like not even i don't even
want it gross at this point i'm just
literally doing it because i'll do it
till i die because i promised i would
but
we both were pixelating our feet yeah
and then people it wasn't us coming
after each other but we both were a
little cocky about maybe we were the
ones but then but yeah like there were
people who ripped it so and so on in
your comments saying oh brandon did that
and then i think it just shows that we
were the oh geez we really weren't we
started it but yeah eventually then
everybody is doing it now
to where that's and that is like the
thing with the internet is that like if
you start something and then everybody
ends up doing it then you just seem even
if you're the one that created yeah you
seem like that a dinosaur you you seem
you seem as unoriginal as everybody else
wow
so that's like that that's what i guess
just like something new
yeah evolving yeah exactly i mean that's
why i yeah i mean that's like kind of
why i don't i don't use it as
it's like a little bit what's going on
right now i mean it's just he's passing
out i'm just putting the i'm just
putting the the video to
to work but my my wiki feat comments are
so funny because people are so mad at me
that i pixelate my feet they're like how
dare you making a mockery of the
community i'm like but why are you
entitled to my feet i didn't know you
were jerking off to them so i had them
out if i know you're jerking off them i
don't want to put them out until i'm
ready for something to jerk off to them
and you haven't put them out i never put
them out oh this to this day i was
thinking i would do it for i always say
i'll do it for a million dollars in
quarters if someone wants to play with
workers yeah i'm holding out for the big
pay so
so annoying we're gonna have to do that
at some point hit okay
i met him he came to the comedy store
oh that's great and i was thinking about
no i was literally thinking about brad
williams was there and he was like take
your shoes off and sneak behind him and
we'll take a picture and i was like it's
funny but i also just want to listen to
everything he's saying he's being so
funny he was what was he doing to the he
was like we used to get down here i was
like oh my god he's he there to see
someone he was there because he'd watch
the comedy store documentary so many
times and i was in it and he wasn't
recognizing me i was getting so pissed i
was like hey you saw the document he
kept bringing it up i was like did you
like that fourth episode was a cute one
and he was like i remember him like not
enough i need more
and then he was hanging out and he was
being so like he was just being the
ultimate because he's like so eccentric
and like kind of crazy and but he was so
funny and so like animated and loud
there was just like a group of people we
were all just like staring at him people
were just like filming him like these
guys just had like he was fine with it i
was like why are you finding this fine
with them i couldn't believe it i was
like i would never i didn't want to take
my shoes off behind them by the way
carlos your hair was a hit i know
everyone loves it you do look it's like
it is fun it gives you like clown vibes
like
like brandon said oh wow
oh yeah i know it's shocking it's like
amazing everyone loves it though you do
look like you look like an nft
oh my god all right we're making one out
of time
i will drive a shot of this i will draw
today i'm gonna get back into my twitter
so i can push nfts
guys hey annie nft twitter please
all right you guys have seen enough
this is disappointing
come to a show he needs it guys you come
support his act he's next time he comes
back he needs to have four hundred
dollars oh awesome yeah but still yeah
but still is the plot is my podcast can
you try the song i think we're gonna do
they're scratched but videos
check out brandon's podcast go see him
me and annie live
this show is over it's been over for a
while yeah but i'm here baby you're
watching you have a problem
just kidding we love you you guys we
love you 200k subscribers please hit the
subscribe button if you haven't yet
we're really late on our due date for
hitting 200k where are these babies
we're at like 118. that's nice i think
it's 119.
you